this is where we left off in the last
class talking about the plurality of
goods
I'd like you through an exercise where
you know ask you about different things
and also different band things and
you're able to name a lot you know
enough to fill up a good portion of
chalkboard yeah and there's a few things
about this we're going to go back
through that and think about some of the
things that are good and bad in our
lives but there's a few things I want to
stress this is going to lead us into the
MacIntyre I say that we're looking at
today so when we see a plurality a
synonym for plurality is multiplicity
another long Latin word what does that
mean there's a varietal technical
company it's a variety of goods there's
not just one single thing that's good
now given in a given person's life there
could be something that they are totally
obsessed with which is the one single
good for them but we're looking at a
broader picture right here not just one
single person's life like you know
people in a hat from the Attic there's
really only one good and that's
satisfying addition everything else is
subordinated to that there could be
healthy ways of living every other good
is supported into one central then think
of the parent who sacrifices everything
for the sake of their child so that
their child has better prospects
with any sort of pains hassle
circumstances in order to achieve that
good that might be a healthy type of but
in most people's cases what is our real
experience you experience a multiplicity
of this there's a lot of good things in
your life there's probably a lot of bad
things in your life - so what are
something that you like
we talked about this what are some of
the things you can we're going to do in
terms of a more general classes this
time at specific things like what would
that cover this will be the more generic
yeah yeah yeah let's say we expand even
further family and honor what's up yes
that's why we value them think about a
broader category of whose friends yeah
you may not actually love in here yeah
relationships relationships might
actually be one of the things that they
ask is what kind of relationship we're
talking about here to it there's a lot
of variety of relationships but
preserving a relationship or making a
relationship that's a lot and sometimes
that people take as a good thing
something out there
pursue think about romantic comments a
lot of our movies and TV shows are what
we call the romantic comedies and you
know what's the little point of them boy
meets girl white pursues girl or do
gender equality girl meets boy girl
pursues point why because they want to
have a relationship what else might they
know this would take us to another nerve
so they don't actually want relationship
why might they pursue something some
sort of pleasure yeah exactly and you
know we can put pleasure in the singular
like that we feel pleasure but think
about it you really feel a lot of
different types of pleasures knowing the
pleasure of sleeping in is not really
comparable because it's not the same
time it has the pleasure of a really
good meal or the pleasure to watch the
package sponsor they're playing Saints
and I don't like the Saints so if the
Packers lead the Saints I'm going to be
like doubly happy it's not like the
playing team I'm gonna derive a pleasure
I'm not watching it cuz I'm solidifying
a relationship or because I'm improving
my mind or anything like that but you
know pleasures are our goods we do
pursue that we do desire what else what
else do you find in here
they're good about lighters here might
beat you know when you're a freshman
gotta satisfy mom and dad you guys are
beyond that right no just pursuing like
their parents require of you yeah yeah
occasionally we'd be after in education
there's really two things yeah let's
call this there are some people who will
take a class wouldn't a bet that every
one of you has had something probably
their major that you have studied even
though you didn't have because you
wanted to know about that that was a
good that may not have even been
Pleasant may have required you to do a
lot of work you might have done it
because you felt challenged you said I'm
not gonna let this material get the best
of me you know that was my motivation
sometimes and then after a while you
probably did feel some career what kind
of career do you want to get you want
dead-end job where you come home from
work every day and say yeah this is
killing I don't know if I could stay
here another day does anybody need plan
for that sort of thing no what kind of
careers do you want what do you imagine
that's a career that's enjoyable do
certain values or may help you achieve
your values I got freedom or some fun
yeah a career it's interesting when I
remember when I was in high school we
had to actually read people encyclical
that was about labor and in if there was
a distinction that was made between
having a career than having we're having
a calling than having a job a lot of
people have jobs I've had a lot of jobs
in my life and you know very willingly
described a lot of them as crap jobs you
know go to the gas station it wasn't
what I wanted to do with my my life I
cut trees for a while I was a janitor I
worked in restaurants I was a what we
nowadays call a barista that that we
just said you know behind the counter in
a cafe was a security guard they did all
these these sorts of things that wasn't
what I was really after that wasn't the
center of them like there was a job if
you actually have a career or a calling
and you find value in your work you put
something of yourself any work right
that's that's what you want I think what
else did you be happy I mean you could
just want a job how do you have a job
why are you going to work this is the
prime motivation
we we think of money for this as the
primary means of wealth but there's
other types of wealth right
some of you I hope will become
homeowners cars right that's part of
your your wealth that can be a
motivation your car is your clothes you
notice we've got all these different
goods that we could listen more if we
wanted to and we've not only put a bunch
of things up there we're talking about
certain classes of goods now and are not
reducible to each other they may be
connected to each other like making a
relationship with somebody because you
enjoy the company
I hope you do especially with your
family another one it's Thanksgiving and
Christmas can really need quite a chore
going home you might pursue your
education or learning precisely because
you want money don't necessarily value
knowledge as a good song or you might
say I don't care if this is going to
make me money and I want to know for its
own sake and one of the things you would
study aren't necessarily meant to make
you a very wealthy one of them you may
know you the things you
reducing your career now there's more
questions I think that you should they
ask yourself from time to time about
these especially if you're thinking in
terms of balance which was you know
specialized study not everybody does
you're doing it methodically probably
for the first time here at this but so
for any of these goods you can ask
yourself why do you see it is it good I
mean you know what you do see this you
know the damn right you do design
relationships you do desire all sorts of
pleasures everyone else does you do
desire freedom you may want you know
well work for you know they don't become
up in the second question but why do you
desire freedom what's so good about what
Kingdom why do you desire but this kind
of pleasure that's it that's a question
you can ask over and over again and if
your answer to that question is well I
desire this because it leads to this
that tells you something very important
that tells you that there's sort of a
range of bliss so maybe in your life
here's a good example this is why when I
was your age I was not a good student I
was I was pretty smart so I could get by
sort of like somebody
got a bank account without giving the
interest without actually adding
anything to the capital yeah when I was
in my class I was writing and I was good
at thinking on my feet so I get AIDS
right
but I wouldn't study what the teachers
wanted me to stuff I'd study the
Highlander stuff no I'd look at the
books that they have that I'd give them
a once through and if they didn't you
know didn't capture my attention if they
didn't grab me I'd say Oh read something
else when I go to the library and so I
was spending a lot of time with
education but why was I doing it for the
sake of plugging the kind of
intellectual pleasure wasn't doing it
because I saw education is a great thing
in its own right
I kind of had my priorities didn't I
because learning and knowledge that is
something valuable not just because it
provides me these other things but maybe
in itself that's what we call having
intrinsic value so that's one question
you can another question you can ask is
pick any one of these any is anybody in
the class picking just okay
so we've looked at things on sort of the
front and now let's look at the back end
freedom is good for everyone right
anybody here doesn't want to be free
what do you need in order to make that
happen
what do you need to bring that back
think about how you become more free in
your life what is actually maybe I'll
take your wrist okay that's interesting
that wasn't actually the sort of thing I
expect you're right there are many types
of freedom which you cannot experience
without being willing to take risk now
taking any sort of risks may be
foolhardy and jumping in and I'll do it
that's well actually I was thinking more
about my history in general history in
general let's say like four minutes
there were a lot of people who fought
for freedom you're thinking like it for
a whole society yeah okay yeah you can
tell you better than that terms too we
are more free society stay then and
mainland China is yeah part of that came
because people took risks and sacrifice
if you think about saving American
Revolution yeah those guys they were
really going out of them because
literally if they screw it up it would
be hung from lens because they were they
were traitors in the eyes of those they
were revolting it's only about one third
of the American population was actually
before the Revolution one another third
of the population was against them and
the other third was
in the middle those guys were really
taking chances and indicator off they
exhibited something that we would call
courage or bravery and there's a
difference between that same cool
Harkins right just taking risks for the
sake of risks my mother actually this is
a sort of aggressive attempt a good
example she died young she was only 54
when she died yeah it can't be came
about because of taking risks
she died wait water rafting down in
Costa Rica she drowned they were on a
river that if it was in the United
States it would have been allowed people
go down to you know countries like that
because they can get to do all these
extreme things here's why I know it was
it was it was about taking risks
just that Christmas before she you know
we're all sitting at the table and she
was talking about this trip and then the
raft turned over and I got stuck under a
log and I almost drowned yeah they're
like oh yeah you know maybe you should
cut it out if there's a good chance of
drowning in this activity maybe you
should leave it alone it'll be fine well
that's that's going beyond was taking
calculated risks that's that's seeking
that sort of thing for this home safe
maybe because of excitement the past
play if you're taking risks or the right
reason at the right time to the right
degree a virtue we call that courage
another another element of courage is
standing up in the face of dangers even
you're afraid right you've often heard
the brave person is not the person
without fear the brave person who is one
who stands up for their fear of conquers
are here this week about virtues are
good things to virtues are habits of
character the things that eventually
become second nature so you can ask for
each one of these things why is it good
there's another one that we didn't put
up there too or you might say that's you
know you might want to be a virtuous
person you might want to have certain
character traits because you feel that
that will lead people to respect you or
to maybe not just go beyond to the
respecting that go beyond and put you up
on a house and you may be motivated by
this they can this can be the center of
your life just like any of these other
things convince them so with anything is
you can enhance well you know what am i
after in this do I want this for its own
sake I've got one for the sake of
something else
you can ask what does it take to make it
happen and we can do this for every
single one of these and we can do this
for any single thing animals these are
broad categories
how do your lives actually work out this
is not this is leading into the magic
do you think in terms of pleasure itself
how many of you think in terms of
pleasure itself I'm gonna get out of
this class I'm gonna go see what you do
really any kind of pleasure will do it
doesn't matter what do you think in
terms of specific pleasures that you
know you like I want to go what do you
want to do after this all of you want to
do something I have some coffee I'm
gonna be plenty crappy food I'm gonna be
you know like you know I got a love that
of an ice skater but you know I can you
know I don't mean healthy yeah I don't
be not healthy I just being food that
doesn't taste maybe you want cardboard
tasting bagels or something how many of
you want to have something delicious
Angeles only if you think of pleasures
in terms of specific pleasures do you
think of say prestige your honor or
something like that in terms of
particular people honoring you for the
particular things relationships are
always particularly right you know my my
sister is not your sister
money of course can change hands and
people makes the items I want you know I
don't care about the dollar bills look
like I just want dollar bills but once
it starts it becomes through
individually these things like this
particular occasion for making way this
way that's the stuff that motivates now
here's two other questions you can ask
about those with any of these Goods can
you can you value them do you prioritize
them can you rank them too highly in
relation to the others let's see can ya
prioritize which is more important and
what you would sacrifice for what you
want can you make mistakes without each
other
have any of you done prioritize the
relationship over honor when you
shouldn't have for dumb things for money
that turned out to be wrong right
wrongheaded that's second bad you know
you guys are still fairly young by the
time you're my age you get all sorts of
screwed up we made the wrong decision
again this ties in with the McIntyre
article where he's talking about
narratives each one of you has a
narrative of your life and that
narrative is not just while it was born
here I'm gonna you know went to school
here
you know I learned this and learn that
it's it's a it's a history of what
you've done right and what you've done
wrong and in order to make progress and
ethics part of what you have to do is to
reflect on it's not just about learning
rules it's about thinking about your own
experience and the experience of other
people in light of these these are the
things that we often screw things up
we values some of these two highly and
ranked them are there here's the fourth
questioning this is very closely related
can you pursue any of these in such ways
that can destroy the other ones yeah
I'll give you one example from from my
own experience made a friend it was a
hippie back in the 60s in the seventies
yeah she always felt superior to all of
her friends who were out there you know
doing careers getting an education and
pursuing wealth and all that and she
valued freedom that's what the hippie
lifestyle was really about was being
radically free not being tied down not
being part of the Machine in the
military industrial complex or whatever
you want to call it now when she was in
her 40s she said to herself you know
well all of my friends were going to
school and making money and buying
houses and having children all those
sorts of things I was doing what I
wanted I thought I was really free at
the time now I realized I'm much less
free than they are
she didn't say this way but we could put
it in these terms I pursued freedom in
such a way as to ultimately rule out
these other things so that's again a
kind of mistake that we see in a moral
reasoning it's not always about breaking
rules although we're going to get to why
rules matter it's about a range includes
the ball that's that's what there is an
ethics when we come down to now going
back to the second question what would
it take to make this yeah that's where
we get to another term and use the word
reasoning when you think all of you
reason what does that mean well you have
the options and the possibilities as
opposed to the consequences you have
you're actually got quite a few elements
of practical reason you don't have to
reason always about practical things
because you took a logic class you're
doing reasoning in there can be during a
history class we make conclusions about
things your reasoning your thinking
about things you're following out
conclusions with practical reason here's
the basic structure
you got some sort of good say here's one
example of practical reasoning exes is
good why must be done what is this
culminating actions for choices the the
conclusion of practical reasoning is not
just something that you say it's
something that you do or something at
lycée you choose sometimes you can
choose to do something but it's not
effective something gets in the way but
at least you're choosing this you're
pushing yourself in a certain trajectory
how do you know what you should pursue
well a lot of it has to do with
realizing what our goods what if you
have more than one good and that's when
you have to lay out of options
what if you're in a situation where
there's multiple ways to go you have to
reason about that and you do it whether
you realize it or not these may view it
in a sort of natural way or you may do
it in a very exclusive way to laying out
pros and cons there we go the teacher
they call it if called upon you can
usually explain at least to some degree
to other people in to yourself why did I
why did I do what I did it's gonna be
something like this there will be some
sort of processes saying I desire this
how do I know it's a good I desire I
should satisfy my desires this is what
will satisfy my desires
I should pursue this that's practical
reasoning there's there's a process that
you go through every time that you make
a decision buster
what actually got you here what brought
you to manners
you made some decisions you didn't have
to know your digit were you radically
constrained you must go embarrassed it's
the only place for you
anyone you could have dropped out -
right
you haven't I'm glad but you made
decisions along the way you know you're
going to eight o'clock ethics class you
have to take a class at 8 o'clock
okay some of you do because of your
schedules right but you've made
decisions what did you make those
decisions on thinking about the goods
that are to continue to find those and
you may not have done it by you know
actually sitting down and applauding now
that's part of what we're going to do in
this class is was make that sort of
thing explicit so this is where we get
to actually so these are the sort of
these aren't the only questions that
come up for ordinary people but these
are sort of typical questions and you
know you yourself or people that here
around
and professors ask themselves they have
to because as MacIntyre points out
professional philosophers are they not
playing people to what everybody's
saying about their we're all on the same
is a little race Alliance some cases but
that's a big issue isn't it you know
maybe there are some sometimes it's okay
you know one of the cases that we used
as an example on the time somebody comes
to your door and says I want to kill
your neighbor where can I find them
somebody who are going to we're going to
look at this investor actually says so
you still have to tell them the truth no
confidence most moral theorists would
say I think you should lie in that case
that would be the right thing to do how
do I look at my cell phone white lies
innocent face saving lives are they okay
not okay
how does my report is your your coworker
he asks fragile ego maybe right any more
work more reports we'll take any more
initiatives if you actually tell them
that the report is pretty bad that's
that's an ethical question what stance
should that happen towards you know what
we call the big issues think about
abortion what are some other big issues
do you manage yeah that's a open ethical
issue capital punishment should we tell
people or not committed heinous crimes
think of any other ones abortion stem
cell research yeah closely related to
abortion issues some of these things
that overlapping there's and these are
the sort of things that people get into
heated debates about because they are
ethical issues who should I put in
office
that's an ethical issue not just whether
they act ethically anonymous but who
should I actually vote for and that may
be tied to those issues when is it
alright to use violence or force you
don't have to be worried about capital
punishment in terms of wonder if it's
okay for you to intervene in a situation
raised or somebody getting Vietnam
whether that would be a good thing or a
bad thing
that's an ethical issue if you're asking
is this a good thing a bad thing you're
hearing out practical reasoning you're
dealing with ethical questions
I'm just hit down through through these
because I'm actually gonna post this in
Ireland goes all the way down to what
should what shouldn't I eat there are
people very very passionate what they
eat my fiance works at the Culinary
Institute of America close to there
there's a lot of debate going on within
culinary circles about you know what
sort of things should
we've been giving kids chocolate milk in
schools Jamie Oliver a good guy a
pushing parents around all these sorts
of issues how many of you have ever
watched you know Hell's Kitchen Gordon
Ramsay's show he's kind of a mean guy
would you say he's doing the right thing
in the show he comes in and he talks
pretty mean too because there's a lot TV
straightens about them doesn't
whether he's a good or bad guy whether
it's doing the right thing
that's an ethical issue and you could
debate about that and we do debate about
that so so right now think about your
own Myers think about where you're going
think about the areas where you're going
to have to do these sorts of things make
decisions that make some people happy or
make some other people on easily every
one of you in your career are going to
have to make decisions where some people
are telling you this is the right thing
to do and other people are telling you
this is the right thing to do some of
them are going to be happy when you make
your decision of people aren't going to
be happy well you may have to keep
yourself from doing what you know is
wrong you know it's not so easy yeah
it's just knowing what the right thing
to do is how do you actually get
yourself to do the right thing we've all
faced the situation's of what we call
temptation right and if you're like me
then you have succeeded in some of those
cases of doing the right thing and in
other cases you failed wouldn't it be
good to know why you fail and how to
change them that's something that you
know an ethics class be teaching about
way competing goods against each other
this is something again that you do in
your life and goal of an ethics class is
to help you once you've come out of it
to do it a little bit better and to have
resources for doing this better and
better
determining what actions carrying out
practical reasoning
determine what actions have to be done
in order to produce or realize or even
to protect some sort of good these are
the sort of things that your life is
composed think about the areas in your
life
you all are what McIntyre halls playing
persons that's why I gave you this essay
this is about you this is about what we
do with moral philosophy what we do with
the stuff you're learning and emphasis
you are going to be or you already are
all these different things you are a
family member or friend you're a matrix
of personal relationships where you call
the support network earlier where you
derive support from them but you also
know unless you're just a freeloader
give support right you're subject to
legal puzzles and whatever society
you're also a consumer a lot of the
decisions that you make that affect
people's lives are about what you what
you buy what you rate highly on websites
what you recommend to people what you
engage you're also a citizen you I mean
you don't have to vote we don't make it
both here in this country you probably
should probably shouldn't care about who
you vote for
although as it turns out and any given
entire political scientists think that a
large proportion of the electorate the
people actually voting don't actually
know much about the people they're
voting for on both sides and you're also
going to be a worker you're going to be
in a workplace and every one of the
fields that you're going into it has
ethical issues they come up but how do
they come up they come up in terms of
Kant's categorical imperative or
Aristotle's table of ethics or anything
like that that's not how it comes up in
your lives it's not even how it comes up
in my life it comes up through the day
to day particular interactions to this
is this guy Alistair McIntyre he is a
contemporary philosopher he's a what we
call it virtue of the system he's still
alive today he was actually in good
health but pretty old he's in his
eighties he teaches at the University of
Notre Dame he's a very important scholar
he's one of the top philosophers
currently alive and this is a paper that
he wrote quite a while ago these are
some of the key themes you know we're
talking about nobody actually works
without any sort of moral theory playing
persons that's you how do you actually
address epical issues that's what this
this piece is about when you address
ethical issues for the most part of your
life you're not saying how shall I
structured my life as a follower of
Immanuel Kant's or Thomas Hobbes or
Aristotle did any of you make your
decisions
we like that we're gonna read Plato's
Republic next week I don't expect that
any of you are going to say even if you
really do love playdough I don't expect
it any here gonna say from now on I am
going to look at everything through
Plato's eyes
yeah and that will be yeah because Plato
will give me everything that I need for
making making sense of ordinary life
these are some of the other there's a
little bit in there about worries about
where you started from philosophy
doesn't begin from over
sometimes we present it as if it does
you know there's a wipe the slate clean
he is committed to what we call an
Aristotelian to a mystic account
Aristotle and Thomas are two of the
people Thomas Aquinas two of the people
that you're going to read this semester
so he is in that tradition he's building
off of them so when we get to Aristotle
a couple more weeks down the line some
of these themes will ring a bell with
you that's why I'm having to read this
ahead of time isn't he just for putting
words in ordinary persons now he's
saying that the ordinary person will get
more out of Aristotle and Thomas's
philosophy than they will some of the
other people
study that should be a controversial
claim finally the fund that say to you
at the beginning of studying something
half of the stuff on the reading list is
going to be really good for you the
others the other hapless nuns will lead
you astray you might ask me why the hell
are we reading this other stuff that
that might be one question where the
other question might be who are you to
say that this stuff is better than
others how do you know why don't you let
me read it and figure that that would be
you know object that we're kind of being
biased by an object that there's a lot
of different moral theories out there so
why shouldn't we just sort of let the
plain person pick what they want to do
well it doesn't really work that way you
all work with some sort of a well theory
whether you realize it or not you've
gotten this far by making decisions by
putting together a pattern thinking
feeling person deciding and learning and
it will look like one of the things that
we studied this semester by the time
that we applied as we go through you may
realize that you actually are
utilitarian they really are a virtue
ethicist that you really are scary but
you may find out that you are you'll
recognize these things this is this
magnet errors point you can't begin from
nowhere even beginning from nowhere that
looks like somebody else's cell theory
already what we call existentialism
the existentialists these were
philosophers within the twentieth
century a few of the 19th century and
they said we can't really have any basis
for making moral decisions any theory
that we pick is arbitrary and ultimately
just
relies on our arbitrary preferences
that's actually a moral theory so if we
assume that from the beginning we're
already starting from somebody's
payments so why not begin from here's
here's the problem
moral theories including the ones we're
going to study this semester they all
have their their image of the ordinary
rational person but where are they
getting that from they're getting it
from already assuming some sort of some
sort of theoretical point of view and
then they import it and say yeah this is
what the ordinary person looks like
we're going to theorize on that and then
we'll apply it to your life so you're
not really getting stuff that's coming
from here's what's distinctive about the
Aristotelian holistic theory there's
certain questions I don't know if you
can see this variable pieces ok there
are certain questions that we have to
ask ourselves when we're doing practical
reasoning and when you are doing your
practical reasoning as an ordinary
person you're not asking yourself this
big question what is the good for human
beings then we're going to look at that
question when we read it on Plato or
Aristotle but you're asking yourself a
different question what is the good for
me or what is the good for this other
person that I'm connected with but
primarily what is the good for me you
know there's a lot of different goods
out there which one should I be picking
which one should I be making the
priority if I have to choose between
them and then you may ask yourself now
how does one realize the good gentleman
what do you ask yourself how do I
achieve this good
right now at this time for my life in my
circumstances that's particularly so the
answer to that for him is probably going
to be very different than the answer for
her or let alone for me you guys have
more time because your students my
answers to these may be very different
but we can put them together this is
where we talk about the relationship
particularly every one of you is a
particular person you live in particular
relationships you are here at a given
space and time you have a particular
history your history and my history
intersect somewhere in the space of this
class maybe we'll continue to after this
classroom but for the most part your
history is something quite different
from 4-month we may share some things in
common so we just earlier we talked
about the American Revolution
that's also part of a larger history
that were formed by and we didn't we
didn't inherit our ideas about the human
being from mainland China Society for
getting along but the history of my
successes and failures is very different
than the history of your successes
advantages particularly I have pursued
particular Goods I've made particular
decisions you are in the same
circumstances you've done that so far
enough to this life we can't think of
these universally we can also visible
moral theories we can say did I make the
right decision forgetting who I am let's
say media takes
well becoming a college professor
pursuing knowledge at the expense of
wealth prestige
that can't be that's all we can we can
think about that that more universally
what does a person have to give up in
order to pursue their career now we're
just walking in particular terms of
talking in Universal terms you see the
connection there the difference so
there's always a back and forth an
Aristotelian it's a mystic moral theory
the way in which you answer these
questions in a particular that's going
to have a lot to do with how well you're
able to understand and make sense of the
universal the theory the theory on the
you know in return helps to inform to
help you think about to guide you
towards making better decisions as a
particular plane person here's the
interesting thing how well you
understand the theory if the resilience
of the Thomases factor right depends in
large amount how good of a person you
are it's not that understanding the
theory makes you good if you if you have
certain moral failings there are only
certain parts of the theories that will
be difficult for you to understand on
the other hand the more progress that
you make in your moral life the more
sets of theories we have you ever
experienced anything like though we're
the better you've gotten something
where you've understood what was going
on I think all of you probably have
experienced that where you guys
experienced that's right it wasn't in
studying off the earth we're happy have
anything to do some of you are student
athletes right those who are athletes
you you actually do understand more
about the mechanics of the human body
and what's possible than the ordinary
person does very safe now some of that
may not be book knowledge but some of it
you actually worked lost you learned it
along the way by somebody saying here I
want you to take a look at this and may
be difficult to put into words exactly
how he ascends work because the human
body is very complicated but you can
look at things and say that's a good
pass that's making good use of the human
body and producing the desired effect
that's not a good one
and I am NOT going to be quite as good
at that as you are or any new musicians
have you played this did any of you ever
played instrument band class or stuff
like that
you understand music as a subject better
when you actually play an instrument
that's why they have you learn
instruments that's why you guys when I
was a kid we had to play the recorder
did anybody ever do that like a fourth
why did they have you do that just see
if you learned to do that sort of thing
he was to teach you something about
music because how do we learn that we
learned through theory but we also
learned through doing through experience
and the more that you do it the better
you get at it the more that you put the
end of what's required to get good at
that thing the more you understand that
thing and conversely the more that you
understand the theory the better you'll
get at that thing will teach you where
your your mistakes are overcome them it
works the same way with your life the
more only the more progress that you
make in developing saying the virtues is
good states of character the better
you'll understand Aristotle and Thomas
and see where their thoughts about three
different narratives
three general Universal battles yeah
what artists well he talks about the
narrative of the bad person and he talks
about this one - one of the things that
we most need to learn from narrative
event theory is it's one of the marks of
someone who develops bad character so
not just you know they're not good
they're genuinely bad in some way that
he hasn't develops he or she becomes
progressively less and less able to
understand what it is that he or she has
miss learned and how it was that she
that he she or he fell into error part
of the badness of bad character is
intellectual blindness on more questions
so the person who is saying greedy who
is obsessed with money where that's
become rooted in their care they develop
a kind of blindness to the
possible values that are out there
that's part of why they will sacrifice
other things to pursuing money they may
not even see it as a sacrifice they may
not even be able to see those other
things
as goods and they will death now that's
theory right they will also in their
life not be able to see if I made a bad
decision here they may not even be able
to experience a sense of regret for
making the wrong choices that's that's
the narrative of a bad character that's
where it leads to
then he talks about the Baron tip of the
ordinary plant person this is the danger
or for you in the culture he said this
is beginning of eh Swami says I'm
telling you a story the story of this -
fall - playing curse it's a story in
four episodes a story that failed us
think of your life as a class you're
searching for the things that you want
that you love that you desire for
meaning we're having a life that's wrong
integrated in the first part the
protagonist sets out to discover what
the final good for beings such as for
him or herself is and finds that asking
what is my good it was the good
you have to presuppose you have to you
have to buy in the Sun you have to
choose some theater in order to start
out you have to pick some way to do it
just like if you're going to do music
you got to do some kind of music if
you're going to do you know if you're
gonna play the game you have to have
some rules for the game otherwise
football turns into base
turns into hockey and it doesn't mean
anything else so you have to assume some
sort of starting point then what happens
well like it says you have to develop
certain states of character in order to
make sense out of the theory the ante
says should here should she or he
solicited by a variety of different
Goods failed yet what he calls
tenderness that's not a word that we use
much temperate Ness means the capacity
to regulate the pleasures that you take
so some people are temperate with
respect to drinking for example to visit
somebody who's a drunk all the time and
they're not temperance they're unable to
control themselves they may actually
want to control themselves and they say
I'm going out to the bar when we can
have two beers and then the night swamp
that's one level we can have a lack of
tenderness and many other words anger
isn't a good example of something which
many of us are not temperate
when you get angry what do you want to
do you want to quit being angry you want
to follow it out it becomes very wide
yours on up and it becomes very easy
once you got angry at somebody to find
some water fault with them and here's
another thing about you and then follow
up on that and then you get yourself
stuck in a blue that's a lack of
temperance yes they scoop through their
code and it kind of seems like you know
it talks about bad person bad days and
stuff
the dress but why someone would do
something better why someone wouldn't be
temporary in an area and that I feel is
a big issue especially in talking about
athletes
yeah he's not trying to do all of ethics
of one article no I understand that but
I just feel that he kind of has to
address the fact that all right if
you're not gonna feel regret for
something yeah you know it doesn't
necessarily mean that what you did is
bad even if your right leg self-defense
you're right no that he's like but isn't
that when talking about the bad person
who's not talking about that sort of
circumstance so it's sort of mixing up
two things here there are cases where we
do actions and we don't feel regret
precisely because we shouldn't do the
bad person what makes them mad is is
that they do actions that actually hard
and they can't even recognize them but
then hold on to things we're gonna come
back to that accompanies the what else
happens I want to get very quickly
through the rest of this this person
who's kind of that lost what happens
after that they they lack that temper of
this they're not able to get out of the
theory of what they need maybe they
don't put enough into it and they don't
fully understand it and they they see
that they have to decide what needs to
be done because you can't avoid it and
so he talks with the third episode or
the third type of episode this
discrepancy is resolved either to either
of two hundred-pound wings either that
go along with rules they say the rules
are the rules are the rules you know you
gotta fly them to follow them that's
what makes things good that's what makes
me a good person but then they can't
explain why the rules or they start to
say the rules are only good because the
obedience to them following the rules is
causally effective and attaining
so you start to play fast and loose with
the rules are only there to help you get
what you actually want either one of
those paths is not going to actually be
successful ultimately and then during
this they find that not only do they
take sides other people take other sides
and then we get to this culture in which
odd issue to say like a portion of
capital punishment how do we actually
discuss and debate things to me do we do
it rationally most of the time we out of
each other we yell slogans we have our
sides we pick them
most people are unconvinced by rational
arguments and we exist in societies
where that sort of thing has become the
norm and that's that's a big problem
does that leave you any way of deciding
what the right thing to do is when you
have a multiplicity of competing voices
each of which is saying here's the right
way to go know here's the right way to
go here's the right way why does your
way the right way because it's the right
way because it's the right way because
it's the right way and all these others
are wrong how does it do that any idea
how to decide so how do you decide I
just pick one is that going to be
successful that's where we'll leave off
for today and a lot of us will make more
and more sense as we go through the
semester a lot of these events will come
together keep asking questions like that
I encourage the rest of you if you have
things that when you're reading it that
bothered you and you'd say wait a second
how can you say that bring them up in
class because that's very useful have a
good weekend and